my name is Orlando bones and uh I'm from
Houston Texas and uh that's where I uh
all my businesses and things that I do
here is based off of that my camera
Boutique and then also um where we have
like what we call our little HQ um small
little thousand foot um square foot uh
spot in what known as The Heights area
of Houston so we service a lot of the
different companies that come in from
out of town but um it's been pretty cool
being in Houston in what you would think
would be a a massive film Town um
because it's like the fourth largest
city in uh you know in uh in the United
States but it's actually pretty small
we're more of a technician Town um and
this town uh kind of caters to a lot of
the commercials and things that are
coming in so a lot of the money that uh
kind of comes into our town and what
keeps us mainly busy is of course um oil
gas commercials and that stuff so we
tried to steer a little bit into more of
the Arts and create narratives short
films and build uh that type of
community so hey so my name is Todd
Norwood I'm based out of Boston uh
historically I've made a lot of um
projects in Boston I do corporate work
in Boston but um a lot of my films are
about traveling or people traveling to
different locations so I shoot I've shot
all over I did a film in Key West and
all through Florida um but normally the
last few years when I shot I've shot
either in LA or in the case of my new
movie outside of La in Wine Country so
um it's kind of a um a weird
schizophrenic life in that I live in
Boston and I usually shoot on the west
coast that um that might be changing as
I'm as I'm trying to shoot more movies
on the East Coast um to take advantage
of the different locations and weather
and seasons and um but uh but as for now
it's mostly uh live on the east coast
shoot on the west coast usually I film
kind of all over um all my projects um
we've been the past couple features we
filmed in Mexico we filmed in new me
Mexico and alberquerque
area as well which is pretty really
awesome to be out there and see the
beautiful mountains um just just
recently I traveled um also filmed in in
South France um in a really cool space
um I can't say whose but it's a very
nice I stayed at someone's um uh what's
it called Winery where two famous people
got married and they own it um I filmed
there for one of their artists and did a
really cool uh docu series with them and
then also went to filmed in South Africa
to do this cool docu series on Texas
which should be coming out next year so
yeah we film all over we're we're just
based in Houston but um really our our
work is outside of Houston and uh anyone
that's kind of trying to be um very real
in the in the film Game right in the
film World um you kind of have to
venture out and find it especially like
I said with our town being so so small
one of my questions I had for you was
like what's your dream what's your dream
location to shoot at and the reason I'm
asking it is because you've already shot
in my dream location which is a Vineyard
in France so I'm like that's what I've
always wanted to do he did it that's so
cool so that yeah um I think one of my
dream locations I mean
honestly the reason why I love doing
what I do is because you never know
where you're going to go like it's one
of those things where uh I found myself
like in Peru right and we're filming
like we're filming in Peru and and and
we're shooting in some kind of Coliseum
that was there for a long time and I was
just like what is my life you know and
uh and sometimes um as a cinematographer
or even as someone that just loves
storytelling um going into places like
that where you can just kind of embrace
the history and embrace what's what's
known I mean I I just kind of uh what
what I would say my my dream location is
a place where we have complete like
control to do what we want to do cuz
yeah yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
so there's places that you'd love to
shoot and then like right away they all
flock and shut you down and all kinds of
crazy stuff so we've we've had those
situations too um and I I guess uh if
yours was the um if you wanted to shoot
a winery in in France um where else you
know um where else I mean I imagine
right now it's cold you know and you're
in Boston right now or well uh it is
cold I I am outside Boston right now the
um uh I've always wanted to do I've
never done and I should and I every
every October in New England it's like
as much as one travels I look around
even as somebody who grew up here and
I'm like this is the most beautiful area
with all the leaves changing and I would
love to do a movie during that time
period And I still um I still haven't
but but I I would love to um probably I
mean I said Vineyard but really I'd love
to do a um like a movie in Paris or
something you just something go to
Europe and uh you know you you um I
don't know I just I love reading about
filmm stories and uh just just I I don't
know just being in being being a film
that's um that's also part vacation too
I just love that idea and I try to con
convey that uh to to the casting crew
and and honestly that's kind of when
when I have cast work
overtime hopefully that I they feel like
it's a vacation if they're not going to
have a trailer and they're not going to
have you know exotic catering then at
least we can have at least it can be an
escape from their lives and they can
have really have a fun time um because
if if you're not having fun doing it um
certainly you got to do the prep work
and everything else but if it's not fun
what's the point you know so and that's
kind of that's kind of funny that you
mentioned that because a lot of people
you know they they always tell me they
we love the way that you think about how
you know how you're producing now how
you're taking care of your crew and I
think that's one of the important things
where it's like you know I think I did
one film in Vegas and the guy was like
everyone staying at the circus whatever
everyone staying in a room and I was
like no give me my budget I will have to
pay out of my own pocket and my camera
crew will stay in Airbnb and we'll each
have our own room and we'll show up to
set you know you know um but being able
to to to to take care of those people
and um I think we did one in South we
filmed in South Africa last year and uh
they said okay you need a full week to
like get you know acclimated to like the
way it is here it's and it literally
took seven yeah it took seven days
before we started our Scouts and then
from there um yeah we filmed for like 11
days but uh I I was not expecting it and
I think even that place I was surprised
how amazing uh the the cinema world is
over there the filmmakers the people
that helped us out there um but it
that's the one cool thing also about
just film making in general that you can
go to the these worlds like and there's
a a crew or a group or someone out there
that's living the same dream that that
we are and they're so excited to see you
and to help you make your your stuff so
it's cool oh sure yeah uh just on the
note of keep keeping the crew happy or C
happy um one film I we talked to a I
think it was a school that teaches um uh
physical therapy and massage therapy and
we said hey do can one of your students
come to the set for a few days
and practice and um it was wonderful
because she got to do it was some you
know for uh study program for her and
for the cast and crew it you know they
had the whole um Contraption where she
where people could get M so that was a
very a great way to boost Morale on set
um
definitely that's awesome and and so you
said most of your the things you filmed
I I saw on your website you have uh
what's it called the tropical island
light lifestyle like that's something
that you're really focusing on where did
that come from going back yeah well I
mean of course it's everything is is you
know find your audience and N Niche your
audience and um I I wanted for years to
to um I'm a big fan of of you know
vacation type music Reay and Jimmy
Buffett and that sort of thing uh Key
West and I thought boy there's a huge
audience here because I go to these
shows and and I could I could see this
being an audience and I I spent years
trying to raise money for this big film
I said I'm going to cast some name
actors and D it was taking forever and
then um I finally said you know wait a
minute here I'm never this is going to
take years to get the cast that I want
in this Key West exotic location but uh
while doing all the research for the
film I found all these other musicians
who sing in a similar style and have
their own very big fan base not like a
fan base like Jimmy Buff or b Marley had
for example but they're big audiences
and I and I would go to their shows and
I became genuine fans of their music and
I eventually became friends with them
and then I I redesigned the movie of
that particular movie to be about a
tropical DJ who uh interviews all these
bands within the narrative so that the
band members play themselves but what it
allowed me to do is to build up a fan
base uh kind of piggybacking on the fan
bases uh of the musicians themselves and
it was actually kind of fun because we
could go to we could do we would do um
like screening and a and a show so we
would screen the movie and the musicians
would play themselves on screen and then
uh you know the screen Rises and then
there's the the musicians doing a show
um and so it's it's it's it felt very
interactive and and it was and it was um
it kind of felt like because the
audience members were fans of the
musicians um I
I I don't even want to say it's like um
Rocky Hara because it's not anything
like Rocky Hara but at the same time
it's that interactive feeling you get in
an audience which I loved like when um
when the the character on the screen
like the the wife his ex-wife who he
doesn't like is on the screen the
audience was going boo hiss you know and
um and when and when the character was
going through some good things
everybody's cheering so um I I love that
interactive uh nature of it and and also
having the music so that's my
long-winded way of of that's how the
island time brand started and um and
then since then I've written novels
continuing that story to continue the
story because I love the characters but
also um continue the brand and um and
that's what I'm doing with my new movie
which takes place in Wine Country which
it's certainly not tropical but it's
continuing the um the Exotic locations
and and and sense of following your
dreams and adventure sure um and I
suppose alcohol too when it comes down
to it well I mean that's a that's such a
cool unique thing to do that I think a
lot of people don't take for granted
especially when you're talking about
micro markets you know when when I was
growing up I watched uh Family Matters
and uh all those um all those shows
family matters even fresh pres Belair
and when Steve URL showed up to Fresh
prin I mean to Fresh Prince on one
episode we went crazy you know and it's
like um it's so cool
to do that with uh with the bands and
people that have that those markets
because yeah all of a sudden everyone's
Cameo and you know them I mean you feel
like you're invested in these people and
they show up in a grander scale and boom
like it just pops off so that's that's
such a cool and interesting way that you
did that well I feel like we as
filmmakers sometimes filmmakers try to
be like oh well it's not a real film
unless we Cast X Y and Z and and I don't
know at least for myself um it it
becomes sometimes a uh a cage that you
they keep pacing trying to you know you
got to get this to do this and this and
um and there's other ways to get an
audience and that's I think the most
exciting thing about as hard as it is as
it's always been and it's some in some
ways harder now it's it's it's exciting
that you can build an audience in a
different way now you know um which is
which is kind of exciting yeah for us
like we we normally try to do that with
our own films we think um you know my
brother's my like he the main writer I
call him he's the you know the goose
with the golden egg I'm just the one
that hatches it and eats it on accident
um and and uh so you know every time I'm
like dude hurry up and finish writing
that script so I can tear it up and
throw it back at your face right um and
it's the it's the best um you know to to
have that and he's so talented um and uh
every time we're writing you know it's
always like okay who's the viewer where
is this going to go and then my business
brain starts popping up and be like no
one's going to watch that you know or or
or only people will watch that and how
can I get into that market so um I think
that's that's so cool that that that you
have that uh you had that kind of
mindset U going into these things um but
yeah it's it's it's so cool and uh I
don't know I I think of our film like
fight boy that that we just did um and
that one was made for like the Urban
Market and like I said we grew up with
lifestyle uh we grew up more with uh
like Steve UR and those guys and movies
like Friday so we kind of took a lot of
the ideas of um anyone that watched this
will watch our film and feel like
they've seen this movie before because
um it's like it's kind of like a Friday
meets Scott Pilgrim but then there's
like so much that's a cool that's a cool
mixing yeah yeah and uh and and and it
was fun and uh so far man we've had so
many um people just just to tell us that
they they enjoyed it's like a sleeper
type film because it's comedy and it's
just meant to you know have you make fun
of of all these different situation so
um but we thought about that the Urban
Market um and where we wanted to place
it um and then we found a couple people
like you said we didn't find the most
famous people but we we casted two
people one of them um I met on a music
video dressed up as a cop and when he
came and talk to me I was like there's
no way you could ever be a cop but I'm
going to cast you as a cop in a movie
and we literally wrote that script for
him and then another guy um named Javier
we literally wrote the the his character
as Javier so he was himself in the movie
and that dude is ridiculous so um when
people are like oh my God your actors
are great I'm like I mean they're great
at being themselves and that's what we
cast them for but uh but they have such
good chemistry and it works well yeah
they're not the most famous people but
um they're characters and and we're so
glad to be able to put them in the movie
and I think I think the audience enjoys
it now are you going to uh is your goal
the next few years to continue the same
genre to keep going back to that fan
base or are did you want to try
something different or like where's your
head or is it just whatever kind of
inspiration hits you yeah yeah it
depends um the first one we did Journey
that one was more of a drama film and um
that was drama the second one was comedy
but when we we started a long time ago
here in Houston like I said it's we're
like a small small town feel in a
massive town you know it takes you an
hour to get you know you don't say uh
what's it you don't say uh see you later
you know it's like it's more like see
you tomorrow cuz it's like everything's
so far right from each other um and we
started a a little film crew back in the
day called fat Kids on the Block and fat
fat Kids on the Block we we did this
thing where we allow them to all come in
get to use all our equipment and we
filmed like eight short films in in two
years just back back to back to back and
that was a that was a mix of you know
comedy drama sci-fi like whatever
anything you can throw at it and let's
just try to make it just up up the anti
a little bit on them and uh so no we've
always been kind of like um you know
we've always just
being wanted to go with like whatever
the script feels like and we have fans
that are following us as filmatic
because they just know we like making
stuff look cool you know um but sure uh
but then um so they know that's our
stories um they're not going to hit you
over the head but they'll they'll just
help you have a pretty good time and uh
and I think that's really what we're
looking for so the next one we're doing
is probably a horror film and uh uh hor
har sus spense um you know that style um
so we're we're working on it now and uh
we're trying to see if that's if that's
the route we take we might go back to
Comedy you know we we have no idea until
until we get the person that funds it
you know so is it a straight A straight
horror or are you going to add elements
of your last film with comedy too or is
it well U for
this yeah for this particular film um we
have uh three you know how everyone's
using influencers and trying to put them
in films and that kind of stuff well we
have we have some influencers that came
to us and they're they want to be in
this film and they're known on the
internet as ComEd as comedy right like
these are comedic guys but they want to
build themselves to uh you know to to to
be able to test their chops and show
that they can act they don't want to be
casted as just comedy Pairs and things
like that so um of course we have to
write it into to their characters um and
that's the idea that yeah there's going
to be some some comedy involved in there
but for the most part um it's going to
have more more horror and
suspense gotcha gotcha now do you um one
thing that's so unique about yourself
there everybody in film making
especially on Independent side is a hyph
in it but you're a writer DP that's I've
never I've never seen that is that
something that you set out to do or were
you a DP who wanted to explore himself
more and get more creative with writing
or were you a writer who said I want to
explore visuals more or was it always
kind of both together yeah I think I
think it's a mix of things because I was
just always like when I went to college
I was the guy that they would always ask
me to to to be behind the camera like
for everything and when I left College I
was like I'm gonna be a director that's
what I want that's what I want and this
was uh what 2009
2010 Rock I my mind was I was going to
do Spanish rock music videos and rock
was already on the decline right so
imagine a sub genre of Spanish rock like
I'm gonna be this yeah so that was
already like the delay of like how that
stuff falls off takes a little bit
longer so um little by little I found
more people hiring me to be the guy
behind the camera again so I moved into
directing but I always wanted to just be
a director now it's my brother and I can
co-direct or do any of that but um no I
I think i' I think my hyen is more
producer director photography because
especially on the commercial side and on
on even on some of our features because
I find the money and then I Ure make
sure that the writing is intact for the
budget we have and then uh and then I
make sure it looks good like that's part
of it where I'm guaranteeing the person
that's giving us money like we're not
going to make your film look like crap
it's going to feel or look at least you
know a fivefold of what you gave us you
know like at least that and uh so that's
the idea um all the time so yeah I I
didn't expect to be writing all the time
my brother had had a stronger um had
that was stronger a stronger suit on him
but um we just collaborate so well
together my brother's very like hey
destroy my you know kill the baby you
know kill you know the script and you
know let's let's make it
better that's um that's great you know
it's so funny because I I looked at uh
cinematography as as such a uh almost
like a Alchemy like like like something
Wizards do you know it's like I'm so not
a technical person and um and so it it
uh I always wanted to write and direct
and then it it
it's I I've worked with great DPS over
the years and then but sometimes we just
have two totally different ways of
producing you know in terms of speed and
what I'm looking for and and uh I just
there was a period of time where I just
said is this even worth it I'm not
enjoying it like this I feel like I'm
moving in on set I'm moving in quicksand
but I can't I can't um you know explain
I can't do what they do so I go back to
I I um I was a big fan of I think I've
read Robert Rodriguez's uh uh Rebel
Without a crew book like five times over
the years but one of the things that
always inspired me when he said is is if
you're um you know if you're if you're a
creative person you can always learn the
tech technical aspects and um it will
help you to be uh invincible and it
sometimes doesn't work the other way and
so I said you know it was actually an
actor buddy of mine who said Todd you
you your own DP for your corporate stuff
why don't you just learn how to do it
for your features and um and it took me
forever to say no no I'm not a DP and so
I I shot a bunch of shorts doing it so
the last few films I've been my own DP
and I'm I'm certainly not the best but I
love doing it and I love the um I don't
even want to use the word control
because I don't mean like control like
controlling it but more just I can steer
the set more and it allows me to work
with the actors and we can
we can I don't know if we if we're
inspired by doing something or like hey
let's pop over to a different location
or uh yeah you want to try it in a
different tone let's let's do a take
that way um I don't know just it's freed
me in a way that um I've enjoyed the
last few films that I've been the DP on
more than any and and honestly that's
the biggest surprise of my own film
making career is like if you had told me
10 years ago that I'd be a d I would
have laughed like I I don't know what F
stop is um but I I really love it um and
it's um it's just a different uh it's a
different paintbrush to use you know and
so um but so that's that's why I asked
the question of you being a DP yeah yeah
no I think and I think directors you
know should directors writers should
take you know DP courses and they should
go in and learn the technical stuff
Robert Rodriguez was right you know in
that sense that um yeah you can learn
the technical and I mean there's so many
things out there now I mean I'm looking
at people's YouTube channels and I'm
like my God like you know everyone is
lighting so so nice now and you know
everything looks so polished and and
it's great you know um really what what
I try to teach people and and even
directors like I'm kind of I coined
myself on my Instagram as like the not
serious serious uh uh cinematographer or
filmmaker you know so I I can't you know
if I have some really cool stuff and
I've done some pretty dope stuff but and
I could be one of those pretentious DPS
and say like hey don't touch you know
don't touch the camera don't do that
which I'm always joking about you know
but um I really look at it as like look
we're just telling a story and the the
the idea is like where do you want to
get from A to B and all that so when you
do have that control you know as a
director DP producer controlling the
money helps a lot to being able to okay
we can't do this because the money's
running out we got to we got to bounce
so I'm going to get this Sunset shot and
hey we got it and we got to go you know
and you just hope that it it looks it
looks great I mean there's there's so
many things that you have to think of as
a as a
cinematographer um but um overall yeah I
mean I recommend all directors to go
take a course learn it like you don't
have to like there's like three basic or
four basic things you have to learn
about a camera and uh just in general
like and it it'll go across most cameras
and you know those are things like if
you don't know you know learning native
ISO what's your native ISO for a camera
yeah you know things like that uh or
even learning like do I want this shot
handheld do I want it stabilized do I
want it on sticks do I want you know and
I have like a little mini crash course
that talks about like the four or five
pillars of cinematography and it's like
a very very quick crash course that I
give to uh directors I'm working with so
I like make sure that we're c yeah we're
creating the right visual guide for them
um and uh yeah I mean what's cool when
we're directing and doing our own things
and that's where my brother for example
he's directing I can tell him all my
ideas and he can tell me how they suck
and then we can go back and redesign the
whole look of the film got have that
relationship yeah yeah and and it's fun
and um and and yeah I recommend forone
so that's awesome that you have taken
control because most people don't and
what happens is that they get stepped on
like and and the reason why I call
myself the non-serious serious DP or
cinematographer or filmmaker is because
I've been on so many sets with uh just
people who are so like they're so
serious about these things and in in the
end we're we're lucky and we're in a
luxury business to tell stories and oh
yeah that's the way I look at it like I
won't I won't compromise someone's
safety I won't you know I won't
compromise your story either like I'm
not going to mess up your story but uh
we have to make sure we're doing this
correctly and there's a project that I
just jumped off of or that I had signed
and I told them myself like I haven't
read the script give me time I'm on
another project as soon as I read the
script I'll let you know if I'll stay on
it and I read it and I was like like man
this isn't something for me and they
were upset because I gave them back
their deposit and gave them back the
script and and I was like I'm sorry like
I just I don't I don't want to
compromise like you know um the safety
and all that I I don't see how we can do
these things with the budget you have
and it sucks but maybe I'm not the one
that needs to film your your your piece
you know what I'm saying and I'm one of
those people where I don't need to take
every job I don't need to take every
single script I I don't need to do
everything so it's pretty cool that you
took it in your hands and you shot those
and and they look great I saw the
trailer for Gap weekend I'm guessing you
shot as well the Gap yeah that one I co
co co shot but yes I learned I learned
on that one and then um I've
subsequently make made two which will
come out which are just pin post right
now so uh but yeah know I've learned a
lot and um I I I actually enjoy the
process now and I I can't imagine not
being the DP which again but it's the
same thing like you were saying with
with being a producer too like um I
would love to work with a huge budget
and work with producers but um just to
have the knowledge you know um although
I have to say it does um I do have bad
habits in that you know you said what's
your dream location it's one you control
well I'm so used and I've had those
locations before but I'm so used to not
having them that even when I have them
I'm like still kind of tiptoeing around
and being like looking left and right
and going okay guys instead of saying go
I say okay instead of saying action I
say just go go you know start acting I
don't want to call attention to the fact
that we're making a movie so I'm so used
to doing it gorilla style that when I do
have an opportunity to do it
traditionally I still um fall back on
you know trying to trying to do a bounce
card with a pizza box or something yeah
yeah yeah that's the one cool thing
about being in Houston is that like you
can get restaurants you can get
locations you can be on the side of the
road as long as you're not inhibiting
traffic you can film on the road like
there's there's so many things that yeah
that you can do here in Houston like if
you want to shut down a freeway it'll
cost you a little bit of money but you
can do it like it's possible um you know
uh especially day uh you know when you
want to do stuff at night I mean there's
things that we do here sometimes in
downtown with all the sky with us you
know with all the things that you can
shut down the street on in downtown you
know it's like it's the craziest thing
you know because yeah you can have a
full police presence you can have like
it's crazy and um and it doesn't cost
you anywhere near like what you would
think and uh for it to be as massive and
and as it is you really like get away
with so much stuff here and uh yeah so
you don't have you know you don't have
to look around you just kind of have to
look around if you're in downtown for
the um unsheltered they're everywhere
and you know you just have to watch your
gear yeah yeah yeah um but but uh but I
just I mean compared to LA and all the
permits and everything else um and I
suppose when you're in Texas too you
have amazing barbecue which is always is
always a key key factor yeah yeah
barbecue is definitely legit here and I
mean we have that's the one thing we
never want if anyone ever asks us what
is the best barbecue then we tell them
you don't know barbecue because every
barbecue is the best barbecue but it
depends on what like what do you like do
you like pork ribs do you like beef ribs
do you like this cuz if you like that
one we'll take you to this spot or if
you like this thing we'll take you to
that spot and like these place like all
of them have great stuff but if you want
like excellent stuff we we have to take
you a certain spot for that you know so
it's so living in the north Northeast um
I'm totally ruined and because my wife
is from Texas and uh she she introduced
me to Texas barbecue and I'm like hooked
and we can't get it all the time and I
just I love going because it's it's I
just love it I love I love TexMex food
and I love barbecue so much U which
leads me to a question for you is is can
you please explain I loved it when I saw
it Taco
journalist yeah yeah so we have a I have
a really good homie his name is Marco uh
he goes by Marco from Houston and he's a
taco journalist so uh he he got picked
up by like the Houston Chronicle which
is our main our our main uh newspaper
here and then all our like the main
magazine Publications they pay him to go
do these um to you know just show the
trends of tacos in in Houston and
surrounding Houston but he's he's
literally you know he's literally
traveled all over Texas doing all these
Publications and all these different
things so he is like a true Taco
journalist in that sense right and so we
we did this really cool piece with him
um and what's funny is that like I've
known Marco forever and uh Marco was
literally at the at the at the sweet 16
version the kinetta of my of my you know
sister and we never knew like so far
later and we went to high school
together and everything that we're going
to like collaborate in that in that
sense but um yeah we got to go and eat a
bunch of cool tacos and um we're uh
we're just testing stuff out and we're
selling that piece um we're we're trying
to get that into uh one of the um major
Publications that they can continue that
that Series going but uh yeah if you got
to see the first one they're doing Texas
barbecue handmade tortillas like
handmade Texas style flower tortillas
which are insane and they're to die for
and then you put that big old fat
brisket on there and oh my God it's yeah
it's a good job to have that's for sure
I mean this as a compliment but I hated
watching it because I couldn't eat that
I was just like I'm so hungry for this
and I can't eat it yeah uh yeah no
that's that's so how did you um how did
you make the transition to YouTube
because for myself um well I I I did do
a web sitcom years ago when uh when
YouTube was in the early stages I never
thought of it as a way to promote my
film
making um and that's really on me
because I kind of you know I just
thought it was more like ah it's YouTube
right it's just people yeah I don't know
uh talking about selling products or or
who who got dumped in their life at high
school that day right um and and and I
don't know the last year or so I've um
I've just I've fallen in love with
filmmakers who who are doing amazing
work on on YouTube both to promote their
own selves but also for their own just
YouTube stuff and I really love that
you're doing that and for myself my my
2023 new year's resolution was to have a
YouTube film making a YouTube channel
just for my film making um clearly we've
we're a few days till the new year so
that that resolution did not happen but
um I'm just fascinated how how you got
there and um and like what what you get
out of YouTube and and kind of your next
steps for it type thing yeah yeah so U
what's funny is that I I look at YouTube
for us filmmakers like the people that
didn't jump onto Bitcoin when it was
first announced right because if you
would have started with the film making
Channel you know about 10 years ago when
you KN had the whole the the knowhow and
all that your channel would be a lot
further along for me I was on YouTube I
think it's I've been on there uh at
least 10 years um but I never treated it
as like a film making platform um I
always I was the kind of guy that kind
of divided it straight down and said
YouTubers filmmakers you know um which
has completely like it's crossed over um
like in a very very significant way um
and uh what's cool is that the majority
of my commercial work was all you know
uh YouTube Social Media stuff um
creating massive campaigns for Samsung
and some of the like more prolific um
filmmakers um on on YouTube um like I
shot some of their whole episodes that
were fully funded by some of the stuff
that Samsung did you'd be surprised how
much stuff gets funded by them and some
of those budgets were you know upwards
of the millions I mean they're just
insane budgets um so uh well you know I
look at it back and I had one video that
went viral when I was doing music um way
back then I was just showing off like
this new guitar pedal that I had and
back then that same company reached out
and told me hey uh we have a new version
of that pedal would you like to see it
and I was like shut up don't talk to me
I don't know who you are now it's like
please like yeah send me a unit like let
let me check it out yeah back back then
I was like who are these weirdos talking
to this kid that's just showing his you
know his guitar um trying to you know
but now like I couldn't see the future
that's why I say it's like Bitcoin I
couldn't see that if I would have
continued on that you know on that
Journey it would have been something
else even if I wasn't the best guitar
player so the best thing you could do
with YouTube is just start and and start
adding stuff you know and um yeah it we
we took it at like my favorite YouTubers
aren't even filmmakers like it like I
don't and that's because you know a lot
of the stuff that they're showing like
it's not that I know it I just
understand it already so it's like uh
sometimes I want to watch them just for
their character and who they are but
like my favorite um YouTuber is Mr Beast
like he's my favorite YouTuber ever um
and uh and that was before he got like
he blew up and and and did all that
stuff like I just liked the way that he
created a whole like universe and I was
like well that's kind of what I wanted
to do with what we're doing and I
created a bunch of these like just silly
film making tidbits that actually I was
gonna ask about those sketches yeah yeah
and those sketches like love the camera
one so
perfect and what's cool about those
those sketches is that we can you can
literally do the same sketch with like
anything like you know uh you can say
you can do it with with like the kind of
water that you like you know you could
do it with uh with with you know
anything like any the cars or with uh
yeah whatever and it's a it's a fun
little short yeah and exactly and and so
we always took it as like okay how can
we mimic you know create something that
works in the film world but they can
take it on and it doesn't it didn't do
big numbers on YouTube but on Instagram
and when other people would repost it
it'd get like 80k views or 100K views um
and uh little by little like I started
kind of taking hold of social media and
when I would go to places like NAB or to
cine gear people would recognize like
what I was doing you know and that was
cool because then a lot of Brands
started reaching out and and and and we
do do a lot of brand deals and things
like that but overall my idea with
YouTube now is to just I think there's
plenty of film making on there uh and
I'm really just trying to promote and
show like my life what I like to do like
you know what what um you know just
letting people understand like the
Artistry behind what we're creating so
whenever I do stuff there's no like real
like uh I'm not sitting down and writing
a script or or creating like a a look or
feel like I want our I want my channel
to look um like Mr Beast like kind of
like anyone can film it you know what
I'm saying and then when you see my work
it's completely different so it's
stylized in that way I usually give my
brother the camera who doesn't know how
to film at all so things are always
skewed or you know a little bit off but
uh well I think you said in one of your
videos and you said something like the
the personality behind the person or
something like that's right that yeah
it's kind of cool yeah one of the yeah
one of the jobs I got the the big the
biggest job I got in
2021 or 22 uh where are we in yeah we're
about to go 24 um but the the biggest
job I got was a a guy you know he had
already seen my work but he said he
hired me because of my YouTube and he
said that it was the personality like
just seeing that I was like not that
serious about stuff but I did Serious
work um that's kind of what sold him on
it and it was you know the biggest
project that I've done and uh and he
said it was based off of that so I think
show people your personality and show
them what you you know who you are and I
think you know if anything comes from it
then it comes from it you know sure now
but would you so I saw that your one of
your films You released on Vimeo on
demand so I guess it's like a two-part
question how is that going for you and
then I've been fascinated by reading
about filmmakers who um who are
releasing films on YouTube and I've I've
heard some film workers have some some
big success with it in genres that I'm
quite surprised do well on it and I
guess do you ever would you ever see a
future film just popping on your YouTube
channel you know for people to watch for
free I mean what the way that I found
film courage was asking about filmhub
and like you know going through that
whole process of filmhub and stuff like
that so I guess I have a couple answers
here one we released it on Vimeo we
releas released both of our films on on
Vimeo um and they both did well when
they were first released the my biggest
problem has been with distribution for
forever I mean my first film Journey we
H um our fir that one uh we filmed it in
2017 and we're barely releasing it now
so that film if you if you watch it
you'll it was filmed almost eight years
ago nine years ago and um it's it still
looks great holds up great and I think
it kind of is going to do better with
the political climate if it changes um
and that's just because it has to do
with like the Border um it has to do
with immigration and things like that
it's a backdrop it's not the main story
but it's just a backdrop that we created
um and uh that one did did okay on Vimeo
um we actually have more traction when
we do live shows rather than online so
people will pay 20 bucks to come out to
a to a venue and we can fill up 300 400
people um and we've done that several
times um with journey and uh also with
fight booy um so we'll do pretty good on
um on uh shows uh and then online like
it'll it'll rent it'll do okay like
we'll get a couple hundred like U 100 um
but nothing like uh nothing that will
pay for the pay for the film you
know and then the distribution side on
YouTube and I guess I want to hear your
answer on this stuff too because um for
us like uh filmhub just reached out to
us a while ago and we we did submit both
these films to filmhub and of course our
film filmhub we're using them to
distribute these two films and our
initial conversation was to submit them
to tub um we're still waiting for them
to be released and I understand that's
that's how it is um but then they they
said that they're going to start
releasing them on other YouTube channels
and I have a lot of Reserve with that
right now because I almost feel like if
I'm going to put my film on another
Channel I rather put the film on my
channel
to yeah grow in my own audience I mean
it's an hour and a half film you get you
know 100 people to watch it you you got
you know that many hours uh accumulated
to your account which helps you become
monetized quicker um there's so many
things that that there's so many
benefits to that so you kind of have to
think of those things so I'm still on
the fence and I don't know if it's if
it's worth it yet but I would definitely
want to put on my YouTube channel before
anyone else's um and um I don't know
what do you think I mean what do you
think about that well uh so the last um
the last the last movie I did I self
distributed through filmhub and I and I
like that experience but honestly
similar to yourself with your um
in-person screenings so I that was the
tropical film so I would go to m music
events and I would have a booth there
and I would sell and I would do really
well and I would do like Facebook ads
that Geo tagged to the the city I was in
so it really worked out well you know
and I did okay with self-distribution so
with gap weekend I spent a long long
time trying to find I said I want to go
to the distributor route and I did find
a distributor uh with lionart
distribution and uh and I really like
them so far but again we just launched
on November 14th so I can't say like oh
hey we're doing great we're not this is
this is still early days and we're
starting um you know we're starting with
tvod so we haven't even got to avod and
and 2B and everything else yet so it's
it's a long process with that um so I
don't know the next step like it's kind
of depending depending on how weekend
does do I go for distribution again do I
do myself but I do have a film um so
after Gap weekend I shot two more films
and one of them was like um I had to
Pivot at the last minute because uh
there was a lot going on with cast and
crew and I did a smaller film so I spent
much less on it so the smaller film I
might just put on my you put on a
YouTube channel and see like hey how's
this going to do
um again if You' asked me a year ago
about putting um any film on YouTube let
alone a small
like I don't know
90s 90s feely Indie drama type deal
Sundy type film on um Sund Dany style
type film on on YouTube I with and and
would find anybody i' say no but I don't
know watching a lot of different
filmmakers um I don't know I've been
following Joel Haver and like f um I
don't know just different filmmakers
folk film making movement I've been
fascinated by them and going gosh these
movies um have no real genre that a
normal distributor would would be
attracted to and yet they're finding an
audience so I I'm I'm I think I might
dip my toes in the water with like a
smaller project and see how it goes um
but I don't know yeah I'm the same way
though if I have a distribut
putting it on his own YouTube channel
why don't I just put it on mine yeah
exactly yeah did you see the the email
that filmhub sent out talking about Q3
they paid out close to
700k to to filmmakers from just YouTube
and stash um stash on wow okay yeah so
they sent that out which kind of made me
think like oh okay yeah that's that's
cool right like 700k that that sounds
really good you know
um yeah it depends how many filmmakers
there are and um journey is one that is
on stash right now um which I don't know
if it'll still be on there by the time
you know um that people see this but uh
and the reason is because when they put
it up on there they got rid of all my
music like they striped all my music and
I was like how how can you yeah how can
you show my film and stripe on my music
and we have proper licensing for it we
have all those things but I think
YouTube is getting flagged with it
because some of them are Universal and a
bunch of other stuff so I was like it's
almost better for you to tell me that
they can't do it rather than to strip my
music and take away all that you know
there's like hard mutes during those so
whole those sections and it just it kind
of it kind of sucks because you're kind
of yeah you're altering the stuff but
but I love the idea you know I do like
the idea I I would rather it be on my
channel um but um you know this's one of
those things that I think it is the
future um you know a lot of people are
cutting out out from Netflix and from
Disney and all the all the um pay um pay
subscription stuff so it makes sense on
you know why why why YouTube would win
um but you know YouTube has its whole
thing with with ads and placement and
some of our films you know have uh cuss
words and have those kinds of things so
I don't know if that means if it'll just
live there and actually not be monetized
you know so those are all good questions
and you know who knows if like just
their next terms of services that
changes automatically stops you making
money so uh it it it's always better to
have your own fan Bas and to build them
up you know that way people can they
know like you're dropping your next
thing but yeah you know just like local
Indie bands you know if they had you
know a a couple like a thousand
followers in each City I mean they can
make a living you know um you know going
around and doing you know 200 300 person
shows you know well it's a great example
and I like I like I talked to the bands
that I have filmed over the years so
much and you know Spotify as a consumer
I love Spotify right but as an artist
it's killing them because they're not
they're making nothing and and so I I
almost think musicians have it worse
than filmmakers but you can see where it
could be going uh when you know we look
at the Amazon payout for independent
filmmakers via filmhub or whatever um
and so yeah it's all about no matter if
you're a I don't know a filmmaker a
musician or a painter it's it's like you
said finding find those core hard core
audience that you know that love your
work and that's that's hard to do but if
you can do it um you know that's awesome
and I do and I do recommend like even
for you to to you know keep building up
the YouTube thing because even if it's
turning on the camera for 15 minutes and
just talking about your experience with
anything like you have no you have no
idea how that stuff pops off and like
people are like just start asking you
questions and that turns to its whole
thing the the main thing is taking that
time to like what you know I've I've
done the thing before where I I like
wrote a big old Board of like these are
all the videos I'm going to do right and
and then I'm like you know when when I'm
about to film it I'm like wow that's
boring and that's boring and that you
know and so I I just look at it as like
yeah let's try to let's try to eliminate
some of that and just build a station
where I can sit down and do my do do
these YouTube videos and uh and it's
worked and you know I've seen it every
time like uh this past like three weeks
ago I launched I dropped five videos
like kind of back to back to back and my
numbers just like like started
skyrocketing and then I got bored you
know but but that happens when you're
spending that time doing it you know and
it's cool that you're not so precious
about because that's my problem that I'm
like ah it's it's got to be it's got to
be cinematic and then but you're saying
you're like you just for the YouTube
stuff you grab your brother he films you
and it's no big deal uh and you don't
overthink it because then they can check
out your your actual film making work
and it's cinematic and awesome so you
have a clear delineation which is which
is smart you know yeah and it's like the
whole thing where it's like you know um
you show them the beater car right and
then you come out with the nice car and
it's like miles behind you know it's
just like
crazy you know you're you're showing it
off and uh well we I take the kind of
thing of that mechanics you know car is
never fixed but that's the mechanic you
you need right and uh so yeah my YouTube
channel yeah it's not going to be the
the best I mean you can go to you know
Gerald undone or to Peter McKinnon or
those guys you know um and uh but if you
want to know like um you know if you
want to know how to film like that and
why they film like that then you come to
my channel and I'll you know I can
explain like I can explain you know why
and you know you know why they feel that
they need to look that way you know and
for us it's like it's like do you want
me to do that one day for my for my
YouTube video yeah I mean I can do the
same thing but it's it's too much work
and I think people just want content so
so I think it's it's fine now do you do
you have a set schedule or is it more
just like if there's a week if there's a
month you want to just do one video or
like you said three weeks ago you do
five videos it doesn't matter it's
whatever you feel like kind of thing
yeah um well you know you can't take my
YouTube because I mean if you're basing
it off of like oh you know you only have
like I have like 1.5k subscribers or I
forgot what what we're at I don't even
think we're at 2,000 but I have I do
have brand deals and I have all this
things I think it's because of my
Instagram but um okay really you know I
would say that if I wanted to be more
serious about it then I would have a
schedule but I did see like for example
I filmed with Peter McKinnon a couple
years ago and right before he he was
going to hit the 3 million Mark and I
remember that he was um uh I can't say
too much about it but I just remember
how he had a certain day that he had to
upload and he was itching like you know
and a lot of the YouTubers are like that
they have a schedule that they have to
hit um to keep their to keep everything
happening and it's also based on the
agent that you're given with uh with
YouTube I don't know if things have
changed like that in the past two or
three years but we did so much content
with influencers that we had like strict
deadlines with each of them um to submit
stuff and we knew that um that they had
to drop things like that if not um like
for some reason the algorithm wouldn't
pick them up it was like scheduled TV
you know almost like the same yeah so it
was It was kind of kind of crazy I was
like and I and I felt myself that I
don't I I don't want to live that way
which is why I live in Houston Houston
is Chill it's very laidback U you know
um you know we're we're laidback until
we're driving on the freeway then you
got to go you know but besides that yeah
uh I don't think that um I do I do have
a very laid-back um lifestyle and
mindset in terms of um even
YouTube gotcha and now is is are there
like other um I don't know Technologies
or like what are you excited about in
the future in terms of like I don't know
film stuff CA is it cameras or
technology or whatever is there anything
that you're eager to explore
out well it's kind of funny is that
everyone thought that the new Alexa
camera which we we're Alexa owners I
have an Alexa mini LF and Alexa mini um
they're my well they're my investors but
um I I house them you know I take care
of them I use them um and all that stuff
uh but uh a lot of people thought the
Alexa 35 was going to come and kind of
like kill those cameras in a sense um
and I haven't even touched one I haven't
seen one in person I really to be very
honest did not care about it um and uh
there are some interesting new cameras
that are coming out um but ultimately
like they all do the same thing at this
point and what I explained to people is
like if you want um if you want to spend
money on the front end or backend that's
how that's how it works with cameras
today the Alexa you spend money on the
front end meaning that your di process
or the digital intermediate the coloring
process it's a lot less strenuous on the
back end but you pay for it on the front
end by paying for such a camera um or
you can use a you can use a red or or
black magic or anything else or even
that Sony as you saw in FX The fx3 you
know on Creator because the DI the DI
process is the same for all um the
difference is that the skin tones just
look right on Alexa you know right out
the box um and uh so it's it's easier to
kind of go into creative mode after you
get it um but for every other camera you
have to you're going to pay a lot more
on the back end to make it look polished
but you can do it like all of them can
look very very nice um so I'm excited uh
there are some new things that cook is
doing they brought out some lenses that
are super tiny they're called The Cook
SP 3s and these lenses they're about a
pound each but they give you that cook
look um so normally if you know anything
about Cooks they're like 5 lbs they're
at least 5 PBS even their smallest
lenses they're like usually 5 lbs but
these lenses are about you know that big
you can fit a full set in your backpack
with a nice small camera and they're
made they're they're made e-mount and RF
Mount so they're made for like small
mirrorless cameras which tells you that
even even the big guys like the the
massive companies are soon going to
create nothing but lenses that fit
mirrorless cameras that are for pickup
and go creators filmmakers like you and
I that hey let's shoot a short like
we're in this awesome location we got
some people that connect like let's just
make stuff happen let's you know and we
might just yeah and let's just shoot you
know and uh and that tells you that you
know these companies that are you know
normally a set of cook lenses of five
lens set it starts at around 85k well
this set of lenses is 21 20 22k okay
which y you're just like hey I can get
the cook look use an fx3 shoot full
frame and you know I'm not breaking the
bank actually I can probably fit all
that into my budget and then use it for
my name your backpack yeah that's right
you know so there's some exciting stuff
in that um there's stuff that scares me
to death which you know like AI it it
yeah it's just one of those things that
it is going to take over it's not if but
when um the whole thing with Vector you
know if you know anything about Vector
versus um of you know doing vectors
versus pixels where you know the reason
why all the real graphic designers do
stuff in uh in design or in design and
uh what's the illustrator you know
because vectors can be multiplied by
mathematically and they'll never look
blurry or and AI is completely ran
through vectors and it just kind of
makes you think does resolution matter
anymore yeah yeah ai ai is freaking me
out man are you on the are you using
chat GPT and those things yet for you
everybody in my circle is is wanting me
to um and I I'm so I'm it's funny on one
hand I'm so I'm scared for all the same
reasons and also for like just the idea
of of any any AI that goes into the
creative process really throws me off in
a big big way um the only part of it
that that does excite me is is I always
you know as a kid I always like like all
of us right wanted to like be George
Lucas right and like do
do the the sci-fi fantasy and then it's
sort of you know as you get older you're
just like especially at the budget you
know on Independent films it's like
that's not going to happen unless you
sell an IP or X Y and Z and so the only
part of AI that excites me is just like
gosh that there's a way down the road
where you could you could do a a Star
Wars right for and shoot it the way that
like I like to shoot movies you know
like really low budge and and let's
let's let's have fun making a movie um
and I I saw um I saw a uh play there's a
there's a studio in New England who does
the the uh you know the technology they
do for Mandalorian the
um yeah and I'm just thinking like gosh
we're we're almost here and we're not
there yet in terms of like lowbudget and
independent film making but so that part
of it does excite me is to is to kind of
democratize
uh more ambitious science fiction
fantasy type film making and I would
love that um so I do have a love haate
if that makes any sense with it so for
special effects yeah yeah so you just
said that I mean this is what's what's
what's crazy about it is that I got hit
up by a company called uh Jet Set
lightcraft and they have a VFX app okay
and U they're they're probably going to
love that I'm shouting them out right
now cuz um they are um it's crazy what
they're doing and they're pretty much
they said hey you know how the iPhone
you know has this little uh lar lar
thing and for whatever reason Apple
decided to do that it's the same
technology that they're using for
mapping and pixel mapping um so they
they pretty much have a little um
adapter that you put on your camera any
camera you want and it'll read the the
environment and you can use Unreal
Engine and replace the the whole
environment with your subject so it will
automatically do it for you it's insane
it blew my mind when they showed me the
example and they're like oh yeah just
connect let me connect to your phone and
of course like I'm like just scanning
around and they make my room change to a
different room and I have a fireplace
and I can walk through it with my phone
and they're like okay imagine that you
have your Cinema Camera under it and now
you know we do the proper calibration
and now you can walk around
and you have all the lens data all the
geographical area data all the even the
stabilization data all that's sent back
to your VFX artist they create the the
world in unreal and you can shoot your
entire thing like if you're on a volume
Mall anywhere in the world and that to
me was just like what you know yeah
that's so yeah lightcraft uh like craft
from Jet Set um yeah it's pretty insane
and it's pretty cool we and we're we're
kind of hoping to use some of their
technology um for the next film that
we're going to do if we're going to do
some like um crazy uh like we say we're
going to do a horror film um and we're
thinking about doing tracking with the
face and being able to change out the
face and uh of of the character and
we're wondering if that will the pixel
mapping will will work for all that and
they think it will so um that's a
collaboration we're trying to put
together for the next film where we can
we can apply VFX yeah on a low budget
yeah to try I mean I know there's like
Runway there's um I started uh testing
out Pika this last week and it's it's
the technology is so inspiring and cool
um for me like personally when I look at
it I'm like it's not there and this like
the time it would take me to to make a
movie using this technology I could go
actually make a movie you know myself
granted not a special effects movie but
um it's it's the the it's more inspiring
like what what's if this is where we are
a year year and a half into it really
accelerating what's it going to be you
know a year from now and that's that's
it's exciting but it's scary too at the
same time yeah yeah that I think that's
the cool thing and that's why I look at
YouTube and that platform and everything
else that's happening and I'm like yeah
I can see YouTube being the future for
sure in terms of even where you know
people are creating like some of these
influencers or YouTubers creating their
own films like I don't remember them but
they did very well with them and that's
because they built up their own audience
they have you know a million subscribers
and now they're releasing their films
and you know all of a sudden it goes
viral and when it goes viral it it it um
kind of goes across other audiences and
it picks up so yeah I mean um technology
is scary it also helps tell your stories
and I think that's overall that's really
what I want right I want people to watch
my film where they paid me for it too
then great that means I can relax a
little bit or I can make something else
you know but um but yeah it's you know
what and I think what you're also
touching on is um and that's this is
something that's taken me forever to to
get to is is not waiting for the phone
to ring you know like to say Hey you
know uh here's the budget or or here's
here's we're gonna buy your script it's
more just hey taking the rein of what
you want to do uh yourself and and
that's that's a key thing you know and
so when you started did you start off
also like just funding all your short
films or did you find people or you're
just like hey I have this extra money
let's try to make this or did you credit
credit card it like uh like uh a couple
other filmmakers you know yeah a bit of
everything um in the beginning yeah of
course it was it was all crit carded and
and doing my own thing um and the weird
thing for me is so I I lived in La
originally for for quite a bit and then
um I I made a bunch I made a movie that
was very personal to me and it won some
Festival Awards this is going way back
and it didn't it didn't do anything for
my career it didn't sell I couldn't get
a distributor and then I said you know
screw it I'm gonna do a horror movie I I
don't even know much about horror but at
that time it was like oh yeah if you do
a horror movie and so I I I worked with
a producers rep and we you know he's
like okay at the five minute Mark you
need to have a kill and at the 10-minute
Mark you gota you know show some nudity
and I was like oh God this is so not me
um and I made it and I was just like but
I'm doing this because it will sell
everybody says it will sell and that
then like a year later I'm done the
movie and the movie that market had had
been saturated and totally died and I I
learned a lesson I'm like I'm never
going to do something that that I'm not
passionate about again um but what's
interesting is is and so I moved back
East thinking like ah okay it didn't you
know it didn't work out whatever but but
back east then the the film that I was
passionate about some people saw and
that's what got me hired to to work on
other people's so I was a director for
higher for projects and those were were
much bigger projects than um budgets and
working with kind of recognizable people
in it and and that led to a uh
screenwriting for higher career so it
was sort of like it it reins stilled in
me what I should have known all along um
which is just write what you're
passionate about and and you know
because somebody will see that and and
um connect with it versus really phoning
it in and I I I definitely learned that
lesson not to phone it in um or to do
something that's not that just feels
wrong and um because at least if you
failed doing something uh that you that
you're passionate about at least you had
fun doing it and it was you know you you
it's a good life experience or you
learned a lesson saying oh maybe I I
should have like started act act two
earlier or
whatever um so yeah that that's um so
I'm all over the place so some of it was
was um I did a Indie Indiegogo campaign
for one of them films so it's really
been all over the place and um I wish
there was a better model like the model
where it's like oh every every year I
know I know where the money is coming
from to you know but you it's h it's a
weird business that's for
sure yeah for for my films I kind of had
to do a little bit of the same um but
you know I had I was just lucky that um
some people saw the kind of work that I
did and they're like well what hey you
you make films right what could you do
with this amount of money and I was like
well you know I don't know let's find
out
and little by little like that's how I
kind of built it up but almost
everything that I I have done or am
creating is kind of a lot of it is based
off my kind of commercial work and my
demo real and things like that where
people come to me and they're like hey
can we make this film and can we can we
do that and um I always have to like you
know instill that like it takes a lot of
people it takes a lot of effort and a
lot of money um what's cool about fight
boy the film that you know our latest
film is that that one we created in a
way to make it super cheap shoot only 10
hour uh shoot 10 days shoot six to eight
hour
days um which is insane the six to eight
hour days and yeah feed our feed our
people like
kings um and uh and yeah and that it was
a a great experience in the sense that
we got everything we needed we had 72
pages that we had to get through the
film ended up being 73 pages so we
shot like pretty pretty like very very
close to the page count and but yeah we
had 10 10 days to do it and we're we're
able to make it happen but um a lot of
planning and you know just having the
ability to have someone and be like hey
how much can you do with this I'm like
well let's write something for that
market let's create it and let's see if
we can make it happen but we're going to
put these
stipulations that's that's really
impressive I mean
six the problem with indie film is even
even the best laid plans you know you
you always are going crazy hours and uh
but to do it 68 hours that's like a
that's like a a spa luxury resort or
something know yeah yeah we did it to
where since it was all done in Houston
we you know I think we only paid for one
location um but everything else was kind
of you know gifted to us we're like
trying to be respectful of everyone's
time hey we're only going to be here at
your bar for eight hours like no more no
less
uh uh while it
was while it was open yeah we're like
what's your what's what's your dead day
Mondays okay perfect we're shooting on
there on Monday well you know we we'll
shoot this and that and we'll get it
done um shot all our scenes out um
pretty much we're like editing while
we're shooting right cuz I'm I'm like
changing angles but not going and
getting coverage so it's like we're
living with this cut you know so like
we're cut we're cutting while we're
we're filming pretty much you know there
is nothing else to cut too and um to
make a dynamic you have to change up the
camera and change it in different levels
so when you watch that film like there
is nothing else to cut to you know so
when you yeah when you check that out
it's it's one of those things where we
chose six to eight hour days because you
know in our industry everyone like you
said we shoot 10 to 12 hours sometimes
16 hours um and it's for me as I'm
getting older um I realize that I can't
I can't really live that way no more
it's it's like a young man's game if you
if you do that you know and uh i' rather
have a regular life I rather be able to
you know wash my clothes I'd rather be
able to have a full night sleep uh you
know I don't want to drive 12 hour I
mean work 12 hours and then drive
another hour back home since we're in
Houston so um a lot of people were
appreciative of that and a lot of them
like when we're done at eight hours
they're just kind of like like okay well
what do we do now we're like go home
like leave you know don't stay here just
yeah go go rest up live your life and
come back we got another day tomorrow so
um yeah I'm hoping to build that into mo
more of my sets where we shoot more days
but we do standard you know um like 6
eight hour days 10 hours Max on on a day
if we need
to that's wild that's uh that's that's
something to strive for
definitely do you do you have a dream
project that you you'd love to do like
if budget was no
option um man I I I I guess I I don't
know I mean we have so many scripts
right now written um that there are some
that I really I really would like to to
do some of them are in Mexico like in
the Yucatan Peninsula area um where we
can go into the caves and go into all
these things like I just think of on on
the more visual side you know how I'd
love to see that I'd love to see like a
beautiful silhouette with you know rays
of sun like coming through through a
thing and then you're seeing water kind
of envelop you know I have like a bunch
of these um images in my brain that I'd
love to to film in some way um also like
uh we've done some older older retro um
films uh there's one called Gloria
that's on Prime uh that we did with
someone it's a short film but it's
probably our more one of my more
beautiful looking films just a style
because it was it was meant it was I
think it was meant to be in the 70s 80s
um and uh I just love the way they do
that so A Time piece would be really
cool um and yeah I mean outside of that
um man I just want to be in cool
locations and get you know beautiful
imagery so yeah wherever that wherever
that takes us um but no I don't I don't
I don't think I have a dream project yet
maybe one day sure yeah how about you do
do you have one I mean not yeah I mean
I'd love to do it like I said earlier
like a star warsy type fantasy if if
technology in France Vineyard yeah but
no The Vineyard thing like traveling I
love traveling and filming like I'd love
to I'd love to just I don't know
like so I had some friends and they
haven't released this film yet and they
they've shot it like five years ago um
but they but they basically they drove
from Maryland to LA and they over the
course of uh 10 days and they made a
movie doing it and they basically posted
ads on Craigslist or or or backstage or
whatever for actors in those towns and
they kind of auditioned them online and
they just shot the movie as they drove
um and they had a script though they
improved some of it and they met up with
the actors in each town and then did did
the scene in that town and it's um again
they're still editing it it's I really
enjoyed the movie but even more than
that I was very inspired by the movie
and I'd love to do something like like
that but like around the world that's
pretty cool like do that around the
world and cast in different countries
and uh I don't know I just I just
thought that some that um it could be a
cool movie and just as a life experience
uh as a creative experience it could be
really uh really a fun way to do it you
know yeah we did we did one of those
competitions uh called it was like four
four corners or something part of the 48
hour thing um and there's one that was
like an international competition and we
got some friends in um we got some
friends in uh Amsterdam to film half the
short that we did and we did kind of
like a Sci-Fi short um and originally
we're going to do Amsterdam Mexico Peru
um and that way we we get all those all
those Vantage points um we're just
trying to find anywhere that had like
fast internet so they can and they could
match all the equipment and all the gear
and all the style and U that one um I
think it's on my YouTube called our Suns
um if not I'll probably put it up pretty
soon but uh it's like a documentary and
like a fake documentary about uh uh all
the it's called our sons because it's
like um all the Suns and all the males
and stuff start dying and it's a really
cool piece because you're getting it in
um uh you know you're getting the US
perspective and then you're getting the
Amsterdam perspective and that's
something that we're thinking about to
to do that we could travel everywhere
and create like I said we have so many
scripts and so many different
um ideas and Concepts that we'd love to
create um but that was one that kind of
reminds me of that like it's and the
only thing is that I'd love to travel
there right not just hit up our friends
and like
just yeah yeah yeah but U but yeah we I
I love that I mean like I said the
global connection is so cool to be able
to go we we just had a group of
salvadorians um come up here and they
filmed a uh a feature and we took care
of them we took care of all the all the
equipment and all that stuff and they're
like hey come to El Salvador like come
to El Salvador we'll take care of you
like you you took care of us and I'm
like dude like is there something I can
shoot an El Salvador you know because
that's such a cool idea um just to be
able to to have uh people that are
willing and and able to create something
there
yeah in South South
afria yeah I was going to ask you are
you I mean your your next film are you
already working on your next film or you
on the writing process or what is your
process right now yeah so I um I really
uh uh Co I was about to shoot there was
a shoot film I was going to shoot in
March of 2020 and it fell apart
obviously and it just that those years I
sort of just said I'm just going to
build a war chest of scripts so so I'm G
to make up for lost time when I can film
again so um so yeah I I um I I'm right
now I'm I'm trying to figure out the
next project and I'm do I do something
that's more
um uh expanding what I'm doing which is
I I do a lot of I call them well they're
dramedies but I call them character
comedies like comedy drama relationship
um uh you know like sideways or that
sort of thing um do I do do I do I
expand that and I've got a genre
project um do I do that or do I continue
the brand I've got another wine project
and it's sort of like the artist versus
the marketing not that I don't want to
do the wine project right but I've made
a lot of inroads and connections and I'm
learning to promote this new movie which
takes place in Wine Country so it's like
do I do I continue that brand do I do
another movie in wine country and go
back to that audience and um now that I
know people over there maybe I could
shoot in some more Vineyards and really
expand that and that's exciting to me or
do I from an artistic standpoint point
do something that's totally different
and both roads are awesome uh but I just
don't know what I'm going to choose yet
so that's kind of where I'm at yeah I
think you're the same you have that
business SL creative like there talking
each other right go back and forth um
but but but it's it's different from
what I was saying in the example that I
did years ago which is it's not like me
deciding between do I do a movie I like
or do I do a schlocky horror movie that
uh that I'm writing by the book you know
it's not like that it's it's two choices
that I like both of them I just I just
don't know which direction I'm going to
go yet so yeah I think we're on the same
boat on that one because the next film
like we said we might it really man it
really depends like right now my
producer one of the producers that we
have um Marius clothing really cool guy
um he's actually a production
coordinator for um Cobra Kai um and he
started interning with us when he was
when he was 18 uh and he yeah he was
like hey what should I do I'm like uh
leave like go like leave Houston go make
something of yourself you know don't be
like us you know um and uh no he's in he
went to Atlanta and he's killing it out
there and he helped produce uh fight boy
uh more on just the logistics side um I
I found all the financing and stuff but
uh he does a great job and um so they're
looking over the our latest script right
now and um ultimately like we have like
a couple other scripts that we're we're
also thinking about but it's always that
struggle as a filmmaker where you have
to be on the business side and on the
creative side like I still have many
things I want to change on that script
um but then the money we actually can
raise is probably what's going to
determine it and then we have to be more
creative on that right um how do you
find yourself um on that like you know
do you feel like all your your budgets
are usually meeting where you know
meeting the script or are you basing
your your script off the budget or you
know how are you working no I'm I'm I'm
I'm I've become very used to writing
especially since I've been the DP I
writing towards what I know I can get
the money for um but that doesn't
mean um I mean well yeah I guess it
means compromise in the sense that I'm
not going to do a you know big shootout
necessarily or uh or a a if I was doing
a broad comedy you know like a big Pratt
fall gag where somebody falls off a
building and hits a glass you know table
but um but but no yeah I probably write
the script toward the budget and and
when I write scripts which I used to do
all the time and and I still do once in
a while I write scripts to be like just
as a sample or to sell or something um
right I sometimes have to remind myself
when I do those
scripts well hey budget's not an OP
budget's not a problem here or actually
when when I wrote when I wrote the the
the novel I wrote sequels to my tropical
film in novel form and those were fun
because I was like oh what if I had an
unlimited budget yeah what if what if I
could do a private island that like you
know that all these zip lines and
volcanoes exploding and all this stuff
and uh and and so it once I switched my
mindset I I could I could do that but it
it I I I was held back in the beginning
be like well how would I shoot this and
how would I cheat this you know so it's
a it's a different it's a different way
of looking at it you know one thing I
noticed as well on your uh the two films
that that I saw Gap weekend and the one
um right before you had the same actor
right on in in
both yeah I did I did so do you do you
have that thing where you're find
someone that you really work with and
you know and and you're kind of like is
he in your other next two films as well
or how how does that work um yeah he he
is he's the lead in the so I've shot two
subsequent films he's the lead in the
the third one and um he's a smaller role
in the fourth one
um but yeah I but all a lot of the cast
goes back and forth and I love that I
love filmm I mean I'm I love filmmakers
who do that and then keep using the cast
but also I like it from a from a um a
practical producing standpoint and a
writer standpoint from a producing
standpoint you know when you work with a
um a collaborator
who's who's a challenge it's it's uh it
really is tough on a tight budget you
know uh and so when you find somebody
that you just click with and and not
only are they very talented but you like
to hang out with them too I mean I you
know I like making movies with my
friends and so that's so that's what I
love um from a producing standpoint but
from a writing standpoint yeah it makes
it easier to write because I know what
they're good at and I know their Cadence
in the dialogue and so um so yeah it's
it's if I really try to do that as much
as I can and I I probably do it too much
and once in a while I'm like I really
should do casting I I shouldn't just go
back to the well um so um but I do but
yeah so I'd say espe I love that yeah
yeah yeah I love that that part of it
because yeah it's like you're building
people up you're seeing how their craft
is getting better I mean you're putting
them in situations that you know that
you want to see them succeed so you know
I enjoy that especially when these
people understand your back you know
they have your back and you know um I
think that's why we we do it lot too you
know we'll we'll recast a lot of the
people um that we know can deliver you
know and uh so that's awesome that's why
I saw that I was like oh that's pretty
cool and you can keep growing together
but what the other cool thing is when I
when I was hired for a bigger project uh
a few years ago and I um you know you
had to cast recognizable actors but the
the supporting actors I was like oh I'm
going to get my crew in here you know
like I'm gonna write that role for the
funny my funny guy who's always plays
the funny guy and I'm going to write you
know and
so it helps them but also it helps me
because I know okay well I'm on an
unfamiliar set but I've got some some
I've got some people on the set that I'm
really comfortable working with and I
know they're G they're going to nail it
and so that's fun too you know yo Todd
uh where can we find your work and you
know what what do you have coming up
yeah sure so uh well you can find all my
work and the links to everything my
books and my films on just my name Todd
norwood.nj in Rage he posts a Manifesto
online and he says I just want a weekend
up in wine country
with somebody not for kissing or sex or
anything I just want to like Pretend
We're like a long-term couple because
that's what he misses most um and he
finds some somebody actually responds
but what he's really doing is he's
trying to recreate his engagement trip
with his that he had with his wife with
this new woman um so that's what it is
it's a comedy drama takes place all in
one country um so you can find it on
Amazon Verizon spectrum and we're going
to have new platforms coming up over the
next few months but it's Todd norwood.nj
uh what about yourself where can you
find your
work well um you can find me on a couple
places Instagram this is filmatic uh you
can check out my YouTube also under
filmatic and then my website is Orlando
bones.com um and there you'll get to see
a lot of the work that I do um and I'm
mainly a
cinematographer um we make a lot of fun
we call it cinematography and that's to
trip people up and let them know that
we're a serious but not serious um filmm
um we're uh we we love to just have fun
on our YouTube and really um just kind
of promote that you know this doesn't
have to be as serious um we have a new
project that was released um in
September called fight boy uh you can go
to watch fight boy.com um or uh it's
actually going to be released pretty
soon on tub and a couple other platforms
is on Amazon Prime right now um the
easiest way to explain that uh film is
that it's a kind of a Scott Pilgrim uh
plus you know um Friday and it it's a
guy that gets um re you know goes to his
high school reunion finds the five
bullies that beat him up and then he
goes through and starts legally fighting
them through the Texas mutual combat law
and if you don't know about the Texas
mutual combat law it's a law that allows
you to uh legally fight someone as long
as there's not severe bodily injury or
uh damage to any uh to any property
damage so it's a it's a fun film um it's
whimsical it's just comedy um uh it has
a lot of language um it's based in the
Urban Market it's kind of where we grew
up and it's one of those things where um
you know we it's a fun movie it's a fun
quick watch it's only about 75 minutes
but I think you'll thoroughly enjoy it
um and I really appreciate you guys um
checking that out and any of the other
stuff that we've created um and I think
that's the most important thing out of
anything and uh thank you to film
courage for allowing us to hang out and
to get to meet Todd man so cool it was a
lot of fun definitely and now you've
inspired me I got to start my YouTube
channel for film making so thank
you